hello and welcome to this video
muha 7-5 7-5 oh okay
Sicilian rustle demo it is this is the
number right yes
do I have sound I have sound okay then I
have six I get that rather frequently
it's a very it is a sight line but still
um I get it on the board quite often a
couple of things that I okay let's do
this 94 I don't quite remember how do I
play that
and then a four actually yeah it's it's
it's a lot
I mean it is the keep it simple
repertoire but it's a still a lot like
here so it should be 2 and then d4 yes
that's the right way to do it and at the
end of all this I've got the better pawn
structure then the whole thing has a
pretty uncanny resemblance resemblance
structurally attune to the Scotch for
Knights it's a simple instruction but
it's a rather favorable version as why
it is a lot better developed and they're
already pieces traded of course in this
course for night two points on d5 to
begin with while here this is often just
happening a little bit later
like here yeah he doesn't play it um so
Luke is seven I guess should take this
opportunity the route can always go to
c7 here
maybe the black king now is coming to f6
and e5 would be a cute way to play it
not much else here cannot I don't really
see ok you can do it nothing move around
like h5 or something but can you have
six looks rather logical yeah you know
the question is - do I go f4 here or not
- I get that get the pawn I can do this
first but that would only be a trade
like a for the King takes I take d6 it
doesn't really look extremely promising
even though even though I get them I get
the square c5 I mean I get to see five
square yet still not clear this is such
a good thing so I'm playing slow moves
my cycle it's quite active and now how
do we activate him no I don't the knight
cannot stay there forever that is
definitely definitely true that didn't
expect but she allows me to step all the
way up to d4 heads that's weird
that's also weird move now he has to go
back okay I'm going to put that on one
form and now I need to get before going
probably the knight is best on e3 e3 or
c3 now okay going to put it to before
Knight g4 s coming up could have taken
already but he has no good way to play
this anyway I think ignite you for
coming
one night f5
yeah okay let's see what he does
h5 I go eh ha
at g7 age 5 ok 97 should be 198 what is
he playing for something strange now hey
doctor I don't think he can
okay if I take t5 now Bishop f4 it's not
entirely clear
[Music]
yeah I didn't really think about King b5
all that much but it's of course what he
will do I was a bit stupid
hmm I don't really know how to win this
this is probably not best really not
[Music]
and I completely lost the plot him
very strange what did I do here
Andres Bishop seafoam
what the frickin Frick what did i do
them I really don't know maybe is
content with the draw
I'm such a that was really bad I mean
this is just a winning ending like here
white is totally winning
and I completely miss played this
sisters haha it's so painful so what did
I do that I mean I mean kind of
everything wins of course and that is
the problem like a knight and six even
that will winner of course but what did
I do here
so just take on d5 or b5 or yeah just be
five and then of course such as a fire
first
now you just keep keep the material and
that is an automatic winner something
like that you just win automatically and
that simply shouldn't happen it's just
ER
there is a completely straight win right
from the opening here where White has
the better position for absolutely like
no risk you know nothing and you just
added a bit better and just like well
yeah I played it maybe a little bit too
relaxed like if you they have this kind
of situation and now was really terrible
to get into this ending for him I'm just
more or less winning
[Music]
and then of course I played it so badly
that the position of all was lost even
it was lost him
this looks a lot like I could be losing
not yet but I'm fairly certain I had a
lost position like here if I've yeah
that must be totally lost at the end but
he was so maybe a little bit irritated
by the time man that's really bad a bad
play okay thanks for watching